même si on invente l'euthanasie on ne
retirera pas le tragique liés à la vie
humaine
j'ai le souvenir d'une patiente qui est
arrivé effectivement chez nous en
demandant clairement l'euthanasie elle
avait des signes une douleur mais
c'était pas quelque chose qui
l'entravaient concrètement elle était
assez peu en relation elle communiquait
relativement peu et puis au fur et à
mesure de s'occuper de la voir tous les
jours puis de s'occuper également de
prendre soin de sa douleur le contact
s'est fait et la relation s'est fait de
plus en plus la situation ensuite
s'aggravant on lui a dit bah écoutez on
comprend on a du mal à vous soulagé
c'était beaucoup plus complexe qu'une
douleur il avait une souffrance qu'on
pourrait dire existentielle c'est à dire
la perte complète de du sens de la vie
comme à quoi ça sert à quoi je sers où
une dame qui était isolé au niveau
relationnel
on va proposer une sédation à partir du
moment où on a proposé la sédation il se
trouve que en fait tu l'as dit mais pas
tout de suite je préfère attendre un
petit peu
elle nous a dit finalement je suis
contente de pouvoir continuer à parler
avec vous je retrouve du sens pour en
parlant avec vous
[Musique]
les personnes malades elle même
c'est très rare qu'elle nous demande à
ce que la mort arrive donné par
quelqu'un d'autre
maintenant une première demande
clairement c'est d'être soulagé une
demande extrêmement fréquent c'est de
dire je ne veux pas d'acharnement
thérapeutique
nous avons fait une étude sur 2400
personnes que nous avons accompagné
jusqu'à leur décès sur une période de
deux ans il n'y a que six personnes qui
jusqu'au moment où elles sont décédées
ont demandé une hta nasik
donc c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
rare
[Musique]
oui on met tout en oeuvre pour soulager
la douleur et la souffrance mais il y
aurait une illusion à croire que toute
souffrance puissent être complètement
soulagé les possibilités vont aussi vers
la possibilité d'une sédation on utilise
un médicament pour faire dormir
la personne jusqu'au fait de lui faire
perdre conscience pour qu'elle ne se
rendent pas compte qu'elle est en train
de souffrir
il faut que ce soit une main dit grave
qui soit irréversible
il faut qu'on soit dans un temps où on
sent que la mort est en train d'arriver
quand même ébranlés
dix voire quinze derniers jours de vie
quelque chose qui effectivement pour
nous n'est pas facile mais on se dit que
c'est humblement on reconnaît que c'est
un moindre mal
pour à vrai dire cela assez
irrespectueux dans le temps de notre
crise sanitaire actuelle et 2 du nombre
de personnes qui sont décédées
c'est irrespectueux pour les malades
c'est irrespectueux pour les équipes
soignantes qui ont cherché à tout prix a
sauvé la vie biologique bien sûr mais
aussi à sauver la relation
ah bah moi je crois que la
pratiqueraient pas c'est la première
réponse qui me vient je crois que
ensuite comme je les dis suffisamment
les situations sont singulières de quoi
serait habité face à une personne qui me
demandent l'euthanasie dans un pays qui
a légalisé l'euthanasie
je ne sais pas de quoi je serais habiter
à ce moment là ce que je sais c'est que
il me paraît inconcevable de tout faire
pour la chambre numéro tant cette
personne que j'accompagne depuis quelque
temps pour soulager sa souffrance et
l'accompagner jusqu'à son décès est
ensuite passé dans une chambre où là on
me demandent l'euthanasie et faire le
tas nazis évidemment il ya des
situations qui sont extrêmement
douloureuses à des situations qui sont
révoltantes et ça j'allais dire c'est
effectivement le tragique de l'existence
même si on invente l'euthanasie on ne
retirera pas le tragique liés à la vie
humaine
[Musique]